there are two very uh plausible and
legitimate criticisms and i've tried to
address both one was brought up by megyn
kelly um and it was basically this
um where do the ballots come from so in
other words we know that they come from
the nonprofits but where do the
non-profits get them are these are these
legal votes that are being delivered in
an illegal way or are these fraudulent
and illegal votes in the first place
that are also being delivered in a
fraudulent way
you believe that there are way more than
2000 moves but you were just focusing on
this group that had this very sort of
high threshold and as you show in the
movie i mean a lot of these people that
were repeatedly going to these drop
boxes
they i mean they look like transients or
almost homeless people a lot of them
they're showing up at 4 00 a.m and 7 a.m
they kind of look disheveled
in other words they don't look like sort
of the upstanding citizen that's doing
their do
service for the country because they've
collected some ballots for you know some
people that can't you know drop the
ballots off themselves it doesn't come
off exactly like that
exactly now in the five states that we
look at which is georgia arizona uh
wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania
you don't have the kind of liberal vote
harvesting where you can give your
ballot to anyone and have them drop it
off that is the case by the way in
california but even in california you
can't pay people to deliver balance i
can't say to my neighbor go drop off my
ballot here's 50 bucks because the
moment money comes in there's bribery
essentially the vote is contaminated and
even a legal vote becomes illegal when
money changes hands now in places like
georgia and arizona you can only give
your ballot to an immediate family
member or if you're confined to a
caregiver that's it and i think you can
see this is the power of the video the
second line of evidence in the movie is
you begin to see not just cell phone
devices moving from one drop box to
another but you actually get to see the
mules and i think it's very telling
because when you see a guy jump out of a
car it's three in the morning he looks
left and right make sure no one's
looking at him it has all the hallmarks
to any observer that this is an illicit
and nefarious operation being conducted
under cover of night
okay so even for someone that hasn't
seen the movie yet they're hearing you
they're going okay so let's get this
straight these guys have the phones
we're tracking these people they're
showing up repeatedly they look kind of
shady you've got video now some of them
are wearing masks because it was also
during covet or they were disguising
themselves but but a bunch of them you
can see their faces so
clearly we can figure out who these
people are so what kind of work have you
done or is ongoing to figure out who
they are and i guess the real question
is who paid them
right so they
when you when you when you see these
meals operating you see that they stop
at organizations and that's where they
get the ballot so the mules don't come
up with their own ballots they they go
to what we call vote stash houses and
what are they well they turn out to be
kind of far left organizations deeply
embedded in the inner city places like
atlanta philadelphia detroit and so on
so they go to these places they get the
ballots and then to be clear though
because you actually show the map in the
movie you show them actually going to
these places before they're doing the
the
drop off actually yeah not only that but
once they they go to three or four drop
boxes they need to get more ballots so
they go right back to the organization
sort of replenish and then they continue
now it's important to say why they do
this because you'd think wait a minute
if a mule is dumping 300 ballots why
don't you go to one dropbox and just
unload them save yourself a whole bunch
of trouble well the reason is that the
next morning the election officials open
these drop boxes and let's say the
typical dropbox has like 80 ballots and
then this one dropbox has like 700
ballots you'd know right away something
is up so the mules are instructed not to
do that they drop five valves here eight
ballots there that's why they go on
these routes and that of course makes
them easier to track the reason the
truth of votes research i think is so
powerful here is they set such a high
bar 10 or more drop boxes because see
let's say that they had set a bar of two
drop boxes now nobody has a reason to go
to two even if you have your family
members ballots you're gonna go put them
in one drop box but some guy was gonna
come forward and say well you know what
i i put my ballots in the first box i
had to tie my shoe at the second box so
you're calling me a mule i'm not a mule
so instead of all this nonsense set a
bar of 10 or more drop boxes let's
remember these aren't this is in the
post office this isn't where you're
going to drop your bills off these are
only for balance there's no other reason
to go to these drop boxes other than to
dump ballots and why would you go to 10
or more drop boxes unless you were
stuffing them with ballots so that's the
sort of technological reasoning behind
the power of the geo-tracking evidence
now i wish we had more video but true
the vote does have 4 million minutes of
video so they have a lot but
unfortunately a lot of dropboxes don't
have video
right so are they going through more
video now because there is you have some
people you have their faces i mean have
they been doing any work to track these
people do you know where any of these
people are i mean again a lot of them
sort of seem like transients or just
probably unidentifiable for one reason
or another but there's got to be some
way to get some of them right well
here's the key point i mean obviously
you're right some of these mules are
visible you can see their face and they
can be recognized that way but the more
important thing is that true the vote
has the cell phone ids of all the mules
all the 2000 mules so when you track a
cell phone each cell phone has a unique
kind of digital fingerprint the cell
phone id each cell phone has only one id
and it's about as good technologically
as having you know a finger human
fingerprint or even human dna it has the
same degree of reliability now
interestingly true the vote doesn't have
the names of these mules but law
enforcement they unmask these cell
phones all the time so unmasking simply
means you go to a judge you say hey
listen i've got these guys a 10 or more
drop boxes so i have probable cause the
judge goes here's a warrant you go to
the cell phone provider they give you
the names of all the mules and then you
go interview them you know who paid you
who put you up to it and so on
so where are you at in that process
so where we are is that true the vote
has been working hard with the state of
georgia but there's a very
subtle and complex investigation and
it's not clear that the secretary of
state raffensberger who's leading this
investigation is trying to push it
forward to hold it back he's involved in
a very complex politics inside of
georgia now in yuma county arizona the
sheriff just announced unknown to us
that there's a new investigation into
criminal ballot trafficking in yuma and
this is of course important because in
the movie we interview a mule where she
from san luis inside of yuma county true
the vote has done work in yuma for
months so while the sheriff goes i'm not
doing it because of a movie and frankly
we wouldn't want him to say any
differently here is a guy who has been
checking into this and in a sense it
provides a certain independent
validation that this is a legitimate
issue this kind of ballot trafficking
does go on and it is a crime
what has been
sort of what you would say is the most
legit criticism of the movie that you've
seen you know i've seen a lot of just
sort of oh here's dinesh peddling the
big lie actually like a minute before we
connected on skype i saw that you
tweeted out it was a criticism from i
think it was like a former fbi guy who
basically just said oh dinesh's big live
movie is going to the theaters but
there's no criticism of the movie it's
just sort of this blanket criticism but
i'm sure you've heard some things that
have that have brought up issues or
maybe things that you wish you addressed
et cetera there are two very uh
plausible and legitimate criticisms and
i've tried to address both one was
brought up by megan kelly um and it was
basically this um where do the ballots
come from so in other words we know that
they come from the non-profits but where
do the non-profits get them are these
are these legal votes that are being
delivered in an illegal way or are these
fraudulent and illegal votes in the
first place that are also being
delivered in a fraudulent way and dennis
sort of brings that up in the movie
doesn't he as well
yeah we address this directly in the
movie and what we say is in a sense we
cannot know for sure because we're
tracking the ballot from the dropbox
back and we know the origination point
is the non-profit so we know the
non-profits are paying the mules now
where do the non-profits get the ballots
now the problem here is this i cannot
think if you were talking about 100
ballots i could say well you know what
some non-profit went through a housing
complex they collected everybody's
ballot well we're talking about hundreds
of thousands of ballots being collected
in five separate states so i say to
myself what is the what is the plausible
scenario of a legal voter say dave rubin
or dinesh saying you know what i'm
feeling a little lazy today i don't want
to go down to the mail and drop box i'm
going to go to a left-wing non-profit in
the inner city give them my lawful
balance so they can hire a mule to go in
the middle of the night wearing gloves
and take photos of the ballots going in
it makes no sense so there's i cannot
think of any plausible way for these to
be all legal ballots so my guess is it's
a mixture of legal and illegal ballots
but all these ballots are rendered
fraudulent by the simple fact that the
meals are being paid and and that
paid ballot trafficking is illegal in
all 50 states if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell